Donald Trump jr. confirms he had direct
communication with WikiLeaks during and
after the last presidential campaign the
organization apparently contacted him
first
last night the president's oldest son
released pages of private messages from
September and October 2016 during that
period WikiLeaks published emails and
documents stolen from Hillary Clinton's
campaign chairman Jeff Pegues is in
Washington with what we learn from trump
Jr's messages Jeff good morning good
morning Donald Trump jr. doesn't believe
this new information proves anything and
his lawyer essentially said there's
nothing to worry about
but congressional investigators tell us
that they see these revelations is more
potential evidence of possible
coordination between the Trump campaign
and Russian operatives this has been an
election for change the president's son
Donald Trump jr. was in direct
communication with WikiLeaks from
September 2016 until July of this year
it appears WikiLeaks initiated contact
Drumm jr. released screenshots Monday of
what he claims are all of the Twitter
private messages between him and the
controversial website candidate Trump
frequently praised with elites during
the campaign
WikiLeaks I love WikiLeaks WikiLeaks is
amazing the stuff that's coming out the
day after those comments on October 12th
WikiLeaks sent Donald Trump jr. a link
to the hacked Democratic emails with
this message strongly suggest your dad
tweets this link if he mentions us an
hour later candidate Trump tweeted very
little pickup of incredible information
provided by WikiLeaks on October 14th
Donald Trump jr. sent out the link
himself saying all the WikiLeaks emails
are right here that same day then vice
presidential nominee Mike Pence was
asked about Trump campaign contact with
WikiLeaks on Fox News someone suggested
on the left that all this bad stuff
about Hillary nothing bad about Trump
but your campaign is in cahoots with
WikiLeaks nothing could be further from
the truth
US intelligence officials determined
that WikiLeaks was being used by the
Russians to disseminate material that
was stolen from Democrats there are
three open investigations into Russian
campaign
on Capitol Hill congressman Eric SWA
well he's demonstrated that he and other
campaign members were willing to do
whatever it takes to work with the
Russians to get dirt on their opponent
Hillary Clinton vice president Pence
said through a spokesperson last night
that he was never aware of anyone
associated with the campaign being in
contact with WikiLeaks Donald Trump Jr's
attorney accused congressional
investigators of leaking the messages
and added we have no concerns about
these documents Gale Jeff thanks